- Hey everybody, welcome
to the first episode
of Pitch Gary V.
A new series that kind
of came out of the birth
of all the hip hop video
and meetings we've had,
but now what I realize is
I'm taking a lot of meetings
and not a lot these
days but I did forever,
and I kinda want to get back into it,
where start ups are pitching me.
I figured, you know what, why
don't we film these things,
why don't we film these
things for two reasons.
One, so many of you are
trying to figure out
how to pitch to good
VC's and angel investors,
and I had that kind of career,
so I'm gonna ask those kind of questions.
Number two, very
honestly, for the startups
that are able to get
through the Phil Toronto
filter, who is the Mike
Boyd of this series,
Phil, my right hand for
the last decade, admin
all the way to my right hand in investing.
For the people who are able
to get through his filter,
you'll see in this
episode how many meetings
a year he's taking, it's great exposure.
Maybe I'm won't invest,
but maybe you will.
So, I'm really excited to put people on,
whether they're hip hop artists,
whether they're startups,
and I'm also really excited
to put many people on
that are trying to learn how to pitch,
and have the cadence.
I just have a funny feeling,
this is the beginning
of a very exciting series
in my content life.
Hi.
- Hello.
- Rachel.
- Nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you.
- Neha.
- Neha, how are you guys?
- [Rachel] Good how are you?
- Good.
- [Rachel] Thank you.
- How are things?
- Things are splendid.
- Splendid, insane.
- [Gary] Splendid is good.
- Scary, terrifying, thrilling
- All the things.
- [Rachel] Also, I forgot my notebook.
(Phil laughs)
- I literally pull it out.
- I literally look like
I've never written a note
in my life.
- That's my notebook.
- I on the other hand
have one page left, so.
- So what's cooking, Phil?
- So, Rachel and Neha started a
company called Glowbar.
We have never filmed a pitch
start to finish before.
- We haven't.
- And I felt that they would
be great first candidates,
because I love their
passion, I love their story,
and I love the concept.
So I wanted to get them in front of you.
- That's a glowing review,
Phil sees a lot of shit.
- I know, we felt really lucky.
We remember, when we first met with you
when you were like, guys,
you did really well just now.
Neha and I acted cool,
I think at the time,
but when we left this
fucking office, we were like,
"Yeah, that was amazing!"
- We're like, wait till we
get to the lobby!
- How many pitches do
you think you've seen
in the last year, for context?
- Uh, probably between a thousand and
thirteen hundred a year.
- Oh my gosh, wow!
- Well that makes us feel really #blessed,
Thank you.
- No pressure.
- Tell me about yourselves.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- Where are you from?
- I'm from Boston.
- Are you a Patriots fan?
- Am I what?
- A Patriots fan.
- I don't know what sports are, really.
- That was, good, that was good.
- Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
The good life.
- We can tell you like
more about ourselves
if that would be helpful.
- Yeah, I give a shit about that.
- Yeah, we do too.
We're real people, people.
I've been in beauty for 10 years.
I started at Birchbox.
- I love it.
- Thank you for your
investment, Katia and Hayley
are close friends of ours.
- So I wrote the first
check in to Birchbox, right?
So that was six or seven years ago,
and I remember that meeting
like it was yesterday.
We were in Starbucks in midtown,
and they were pitching and
they probably got about
60 words in, and I said I was in.
And I remember them getting super pumped
and emotional, and pretty emotional,
and I remember like
awesome, I was pumped too,
and they were just like, "We've gotten
so many No's, we needed this Yes."
I was like cool, I've seen that before,
I didn't think much of it,
and it was super interesting,
it was probably around this time of year,
it was that first really
nice day in New York City,
after the winter, you
know like that perfect,
I don't know if it was like April or May,
but it was that day.
I think we all know what day that was.
I was ironically less busy back then,
so I could actually walk home.
I live on the Upper East Side.
In that 30 block walk,
I remember somewhere
around halfway being like,
"Wait a minute, is it possible?"
The business was so obvious to me,
it was like we're gonna
get samples and sell them.
I was like, that's a
great fucking business.
(audience laughs)
- Katia's an investor in Glowbar,
and I was there for four years,
led our partnerships team, so
really like pitching brands,
- Did we meet in that
one meeting I came when
I was in that conference room?
- With Jab, Jab, Hook, yeah.
- It's so funny, you
walked in and I'm like
God, this fucking face,
I definitely feel like.
- Wow, good memory!
- Can I tell you a
weird thing?
I was thinking of bringing the book
to get you to sign it,
but then I was like,
"Rachel, don't be thirsty."
Don't embarrass Neha
and bring a fucking book
and be like, "Can you sign this?"
- It's so funny, when you
walked in I'm like god,
I really feel like we've, like I really,
that's super cool, I remember
that meeting very well.
- Yeah and that was a
really cool thing we did.
We had every month, we had
an entrepreneur come talk
to us and teach us what worked for them,
what didn't, like any advice.
And I remember it was our
best team building thing
that they ever did.
So I was there for four years, left,
I learned the startup space
and the venture box space,
but really wanted to learn
how like a sole proprietor
owned a business and ran a business
and how it was all operated.
So I went to Beauty Blender, the world's
number one makeup sponge, and worked there
for the past three and half years
and really realized I
wanted to do my own thing.
- Good for you.
- And then Neha and I found one another,
we manifested one another.
- Yup.
- She can tell you a bit about herself.
- So I previously was
a management consultant
at Banning Company.
Spent a lot of time in their
consumer and retail practices,
and got really obsessed with
thinking about the consumer.
When you're a management
consultant, I really
wasn't able to kind of get into that
side of the business.
So I externed for Henry Davis,
the COO of Glossier,
ahead of their series C,
so just thinking about like
different strategic initiatives
that they were, had top
of mind at the time.
And really understanding
how a company that focuses
on consumer, is actually
doing that operationally,
and what they're putting in place.
- [Gary] Always.
- Which was really really
cool insight to get.
Coming out of that, I was like okay
I want to try this, I want
to put this to practice.
Sent that to a colleague,
Rachel had also sent it
to a colleague, and the colleague was like
you two should meet.
- No way.
- Yeah.
And we're like,
- Do you have like a statue
of this person in the office?
- Her name is Alyssa, shout out to Alyssa.
She's an amazing marketer, actually,
and she just saw that we were completely
different people, but could come together
and really build something amazing.
- Yeah, you guys are gonna have to like,
we have to make a shrine for her.
- And we're working on it.
- We actually should do more for her.
- I know.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- We've thanked her and
sent her a heart emoji.
- The best way you could
thank her is to like,
Easter Eggs within your business.
- So yeah, we're really.
- So what's the business?
- You wanna go?
- Sure.
- You want me to go?
- So, at the end of the
day, what we're really
trying to do is help people
take better care of their skin.
And we want to do that A) in person,
and also B) online.
So as we think about it in person,
it's really being an expert for her
and providing skin care treatments
because we think she needs to be seeing
someone professional at least once a month
to take better care of her skin.
To really make her at-home routine
work and be more effective.
- What are most women doing now?
- Yeah, so most women are taking care
of their skin at home and trial and error.
It's a complete shit show, Gary,
like everyone's buying stuff at Sephora,
they're looking on
YouTube for like tutorials
on how to do a mask or
how to use a product.
And then they're going
to their dermatologist
once a year or twice a year.
- Once or twice a year.
- Yeah.
- And what's a facial?
I'm being serious.
I mean I know what it is, but like,
what is it in the practice of this?
- So a facial is about an
hour and a half appointment
as it stands today and
it's about 12 steps.
- Yeah.
- They wash your face ad nauseum,
they massage your shoulders.
- They've got that, I've done two,
they do like the foggy, steamy thing.
- Yeah.
- When you're like
sweating down your neck.
- Right, it's like down your
ears, and they leave you,
and they're like see you in 10 minutes
and then they come back,
and it takes forever,
so the consumer opts out.
They're not taking care of their skin
because it takes too long,
it's expensive, it's $150 on average,
and they don't know who to trust.
- So is that what you're disrupting?
- Yeah,
- Exactly.
- Faster, better priced,
more contemporary?
- Yup, effective and,
- Thirty minute treatment only.
- Only?
- Yup.
- Max or min too, thirty?
- Thirty.
- Next, how many places do this?
How many locations do you have?
- We're opening our first in Q2.
- That's awesome, good for you, where?
- Tribeca.
- Good, okay.
- We're excited.
- Thirty minutes only,
and what have you been doing
so far, like visiting people?
- So we are just getting started,
so what we've been doing is figuring out
what happens in those 30 minutes,
so we've been testing all of
the protocols we want to do,
how we want to do them and also,
how we want to
- Like has this been
on friends and family,
are like people just coming over,
like you're doing them?
- Yeah, so we actually have a partnership
with an aesthetics
school outside of Boston
that actually my grandmother started.
- That's great.
- So it's a legacy, it's really like
if you asked me why I'm doing this
not only am I hungry and
just like fucking want my
own business, but like my grandmother
pioneered skin care and I
really want to modernize it.
- Your grandmother pioneering skin care,
like super documented,
like in google searches,
like or is she alive?
- We're the first
accredited aesthetics school
in the country.
- Is she alive?
- Yeah, she is.
- That's amazing.
- She has dementia so
she doesn't really know
what's going on.
- My grandma does too.
- But sometimes when my mom will be like,
"Rachel's opening a salon,"
because it's like the best
way to get into her brain,
she'll be like,
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah,
- I think she gets it!
Yay!
And other days, she's like mm-hmmm,
and we're like okay, it's not worth it.
- Like who is this woman
and get her out of my, yeah.
- So we have a partnership
with our aesthetics school.
And that's where we really consider that
to be like our R&D department.
- Makes sense.
- And we go there and we've not only had
focus groups with the esthetician there,
but also done all of our protocols
and tested there three times now.
We have proof of our protocols.
- Keep going.
- Yeah, so we're,
- What's happening online?
- So in terms of online, there's
obviously consumers are really looking
at their phones a lot and on their
computers a lot, and so when we think
about educating her more in this space
and telling her about what treatment
did you just receive?
Why did you receive that?
What should you do at home?
What should you not do at home?
We want to have those
communications online,
and so, we're starting
with follow-up emails
right after that kind of tell her
everything that happened
during that treatment.
And we're able to do that because we're
putting tech in place in our studios
that is going to be
recording all of this data
that's happening during the treatment
and then communicating that back to her.
- Understood.
- And why that's really
important to the process
is that no one is doing that today.
- Can I give you a huge piece of advice?
- Yeah.
- That's what we're here for.
- I really think that
you need to deliver that
content in multiple
forms, predicated on how
she wants to consume it.
Your ability to transcribe
that information
into voice or even long term eventually,
transcribe it visually,
is something you should
give a lot of thought to.
The amount of companies that have failed
or have struggled to get
the traction they wanted
because they predicated on a singular form
of written communication
that doesn't map to
her life, like I would
never read that email.
I don't read emails of clients giving me
three million dollars.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- So I have full-time, like
so I think for not a big investment,
a disproportionate
leverage could be for you
that subtle form of communication.
Like, before you started even going down
the path, it's pattern recognition,
I know where, what you're about to say,
you're gonna have to bridge to that.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- You're probably not gonna
raise the kind of capital
that's gonna allow you to
have six, seven full-time,
you know?
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- So, I do think that
subtle communication in the
beginning is a much, much
bigger deal than people realize.
- Yeah.
And it's not being done at all today,
so I think that the
loop with the consumer,
if we get her in to our space,
give her an amazing experience,
and then connect with her after
and get her back in, that's where we're
really gonna retain her and
get that lifetime value.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And no one's doing that today,
it's like the conversation
starts in the salon,
and then it stops because
they don't do any follow up.
- Also to a very small
group of individuals.
- [Rachel] Right.
- Right, like if it's an hour and a half
and it's expensive, you're talking about
high net worth women.
- [Rachel] Right.
- I don't know how many $150 facials are
happening in places that are more
middle class or you know?
- Yeah, so we're definitely targeting
the 30 to 45 year old woman also,
which is like a big white space in beauty,
people are all talking to the Millennial.
- [Gary] Agreed.
- And we really,
- That's why I bought PureWow.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Right?
- Nobody agrees more than me.
- And by the way, that's
the only email subscription
that I still subscribe to
as a 33 year old woman.
I love PureWow.
- And former neighbor of Ryan Harwood.
- I love it.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- That's probably why
you're still up here.
Subconscious bias.
- Not for the Glowbar
but because of PureWow.
- [Gary] Okay
- So we're targeting that
30 to 45 year old woman
and we really believe we're
going to be finding her
on Instagram and on Facebook, obviously,
but even more importantly,
we really believe
in earned media.
I think that's important to say because
our experience is our marketing.
We don't have a marketing budget of like
a million dollars to start.
We're raising only a million dollars.
- Yes.
- So we really need to make sure,
that puts the onus on Neha and I to
build like a kick-ass experience for her
so that she comes in, loves it,
and then talks about it.
And that's how we're gonna win,
is organic growth at the beginning.
And grassroots and some other exciting
initiatives that we have planned,
but we think are pretty scrappy and fun.
- Clever.
- Clever, yes, that's
one of our brand tenets.
Eventually, we'll get
into some paid stuff.
- So it's literally physical,
the digital part, you think
there's a revenue stream
on the digital side, or
is it a retention thing?
- So to start, it'll
be primarily retention.
So that physical experience,
that brick and mortar,
is really our channel when we start.
Over time, five years from now, when
the landscape really starts changing
is when the digital
landscapes becomes more
of a revenue stream, and we think of
how do you actually make
her a digital member?
How do you engage the girl who's
- When you say the landscape
changes over five years,
do you think the technology advances
that allow the tele- work
to be really meaningful
because the clarity of being
able to analyze the skin
through a mobile device, or the landscape
of your business just growing to a scale
where that could become meaningful?
- Yeah, I think it's one of the two.
So I think, right now the
habit doesn't even exist
for her to comes once a month
and so to form that habit, we
need those physical spaces.
But as that habit is
formed, and as people become
more comfortable with
talking to estheticians,
they don't really need
that physical interaction.
- One thing I love about you guys is
how little money you're taking,
because that's my dream,
- Everyone tells us to take more.
- Of course because that means not smart.
Everyone just cares about banking.
- It's insane.
- Yeah.
- Everybody says that because they economy
has been flourishing for a decade
and there's so much money in the system.
- You know we've had more investors pass
because we aren't accepting enough money
than giving us money?
It's a wild experience.
It's fucking too small of a challenge.
- By the way, it's also a very clever way
that VC's like to say pass,
- Right, right, it's
like oh, you're too early
well so is the other company,
- But, but, but, what I will say
is you have a capital intensive business
if you're going to go physical
location rollout, right?
- [Neha] Yeah.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- Like Tribeca rent isn't cheap.
- So.
- It's not, but,
so there's two folds to that, one is,
we've really adjusted our
real estate strategy for that
so rather than building the big flagships,
we actually asked ourselves,
well how small can we make this
without compromising the experience?
- That makes sense.
- So what we've done is
lowered our build out costs,
rents, relative to others in this space.
Beyond that, the payback
period is actually pretty
quick for this kind of business,
especially because the
margins are pretty good,
and so it actually
gives us a bit of runway
so if I put down $200k
to build out a space,
within six to eight months
we've made that back.
- [Gary] Right.
- So that kind of helps
our initial investment
into going into this brick and mortar.
- Listen, I respect that.
I built an eCommerce wine business
on top of a brick and mortar store,
which allowed me to do it, right?
So I understand that, so
you feel like you've been
able to not compromise experience,
how much are you gonna do it for?
How much is the price point?
- 70.
- 70, so you're saying pretty hard core,
facials in the city are a buck fifty,
the floor for an hour and a half?
Is that right?
- [Rachel] Yes.
- Or average?
- It's average.
- Yup.
- So do you believe
that, one thing that runs
through my mind, do you believe that if
the woman is thinking okay
I'm paying a buck fifty,
a buck twenty, a buck seventy,
for an hour and a half,
that 70 for 30, do you
think that some people
are basic and they're just thinking,
shit it's actually amortized out to 210?
Is your big comms challenge gonna be
that you're gonna get
the results you need,
because you just made me common gal,
but just human, human, oh you're premium,
because you're 210.
- Yeah.
- I think one thing
that you'll have a real
challenge of is, and
it's a good challenge,
back to like your clever marketing stunts,
I highly recommend that
for the four dollars
you do have allocated for comms
and things of that nature,
that you better,
- [Rachel] That's a big part of our plan.
- You better.
- Yeah, we have to talk about how
although we have a lower price point
and a lower amount of
time, we've taken out all
- I have such a big idea.
- Tell us.
- Talk to us.
- I think time is the number
one valuable thing on earth.
I think that you should do as
much clever shit as possible
in telling these women,
what the average woman can
do with an extra hour a day.
- Wait, I have a list of this.
And I have a list of everything
you can do in 30 minutes,
Crest White Strips, an episode
of Friends, and all that,
and then what you can do if
you save yourself an hour.
- You should, you should,
I would lean into the hour.
The half an hour, like
this is just psychology,
by the way, you should do both, but
my intuition is that the hour,
if you do a whole campaign of what would
you do with an extra hour,
and basically just shit
on the industry for wasting an hour,
like we're not women
that have nothing to do.
- That's so smart.
- Yeah.
- That's empowering, on trend,
like fuck you establishment,
we have shit to do.
- Do you think that makes
us have a little bit
of a negative connotation?
- Listen, I think that to your point,
this is one point of view and
one tone of the execution.
My intuition and what my thesis is,
is you do a bunch of them.
- [Rachel] Okay
- Like one of them could be like
you can do something nice
for your mother in law.
That sounds like you're wonderful.
- [Neha] Right.
- Listen, I do think it's
always smart to be like,
"fuck the man."
Like you made us waste an
hour, I do think it plays.
Especially, if you're
cheeky and not as serious
to your point.
- [Rachel] Okay
- I think that you should,
you're always one comm,
interview, one clever
Instagram post away,
I do think it's a very
powerful pillar to play on.
- [Rachel] Okay
- I believe in voice,
strictly on the time savings.
I finally understood Uber
when I understood they were
selling time.
You know like, time.
Amazon's winning because of time.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- Time.
So, just the sheer amount
of like really deeply
leaning into like who's got
an hour to waste, no one.
- Right, no one.
- Yeah.
- Especially the demo we're targeting.
- Correct.
- We were actually just, we had someone
ask us like, you guys are
doing something that's very
effective and you're doing
it in an efficient way,
you just have to ask
yourselves does the consumer
value efficiency?
And Rachel and I were like I think so.
- Right, because whoever said that to you
went too cliche like, oh
women loved to be pampered.
Like sure, three times a year when
you have a fucking hour.
- [Rachel] Thank you, on vacation.
- You're preaching, you're preaching.
You're preaching.
- They're coming to us
because they have a problem
that they want solved and they need help.
- And what I think is
better than blowing out
your hair is that you're
talking about something
very macro.
So the thing I like
about it, it's not more
dentist than blowing out your hair,
but it's definitely more
in between, like right?
- We were just talking about this earlier.
- So to me, yeah, I
think you're in between.
- We're in between like a derm appointment
and a traditional spa.
Because we're solutions oriented,
which is what the consumer wants to hear.
- And how often do you think they should,
like every woman's skin
is different, I get it.
- Monthly.
- Monthly, once a month.
- Really what we talk about a lot is like
- Will you sell, have
you thought about selling
yearly subscription then?
- Yeah, memberships, yeah.
- Birchbox is in my core.
- [Gary] I get it.
So, is there a better deal
than $840 for the year?
- Yeah.
- You'll have like 15%, 10 to 15%,
is like the industry norm.
- Yeah, and you'll get a
percentage off retail product
we sell.
And the difference between
us and like others,
is that we're really partnering
with professional brands
which ups our credibility.
We're not partnering
with those you can find
at Sephora, Blue Mercury,
- Salon only brand type stuff,
that whole dermo brand
- Professional brands that are only sold
through the esthetician
which really elevates
our estheticians because we actually care
just as much about the
client as our estheticians.
Our labor force is what
our business is built on.
- You should care more
about the estheticians.
- Exactly.
- We do.
And we're actually
paying them like 25% more
than the industry average in the city.
We're hoping to like
- [Gary] Smart.
- Really build a career
oriented labor model.
- Have you thought about
building their brands,
even though that creates
a vulnerability for you?
- Building the brands
that we're working with?
- No, the estheticians.
- Oh, we've thought a lot about that.
- Can I give you a huge piece of advice?
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- You should disproportionately
try to make them famous.
- So we talk a lot about
how they're our movie stars.
- You should disproportionately
try to make them famous.
The number one mistakes,
that all these companies
are making right now,
in exercise, in everything else,
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- Is they're scared to let
them build their brands
because then they have
leverage and then they leave.
- But they don't all leave.
- Of course not.
And more importantly, if
you're known for building
brands, they'll all come to you.
- [Neha] Right, right.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- You'll have a pipeline greater
than the people that leave.
- That's so smart.
- Yup.
- Like you should almost
literally build an internal
agency of personal
brands for these people,
it will become a singular
point of leverage
for you and your industry.
- Yeah, I think we're
committed to that for sure.
We're really excited about hiring,
- I really, really can't stress it enough.
- Okay
- It's helpful to hear.
- Yeah.
- The second you, with 59
goddamn Instagram followers,
but with press because you've launched,
show post three, this is
Karen, here's her story,
we love her, every other
industry professional
looks at them and be like,
my place would never do that.
- [Rachel] Yeah, right.
- [Neha] Right.
And they get excited.
- Yeah.
And then they retain clients also.
- Yeah and listen, a bunch will
leave and do it personally,
I'm just telling you, that's firm.
Not as much in the net result.
- [Rachel] Exactly.
- It's the number one mistake
that every single professional service,
like provider kind of
company is making right now.
They're trying to put the
internet back in the box.
I'm trying to make D-rock the most things,
I've turned him into a
fucking verb and noun.
- When I saw him I was
like, is that D-rock?
I was like oh my god, we
need a picture with him.
- So this is back to
like actions over words.
I believe in it the most.
- It's something we're
really committed to.
- It's something not
natural to the industry.
- Yeah, that's for sure.
- Salons don't want their, like,
they all suppress,
they suppress.
- They don't let them
stand into their light.
- You'll have disproportionate funnel.
I think out of all things,
like we're talking here
a little bit.
The one hour and these two things,
look a young company is about decisions.
- Yup.
- It's about decisions.
Like when I think about Vayner,
it was like making a decision to like make
a lot of social media content
is why we're sitting here
today in the forum that we are.
- Yeah.
- Right, like deciding that I had to have
big time media capabilities
when I started to sense
any kind of organic reach drop,
there's decisions.
Like, hiring only friends at first
because I wanted a culture of that.
Like these meetings, like,
there's a real reason Phil
takes 2,000 meetings a year,
it's because after I was doing them,
back in the day, a lot of
people wanted them all the time
and that didn't scale for me.
These are important decisions.
And you have to be very thoughtful
about what you lean in to, like
for example, if you thought I was right,
and you do lean in to building out
them, that takes time and effort.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- That's strategy.
That's you not thinking about you,
or the customer, that's talking about the
most important asset.
But it can become so disruptive,
it can be the game changer.
- And so defensible against
our other competitors
in this space.
- In a way that's funny
because you're vulnerable.
That's your strength.
- Yeah, I like that.
- Why'd you like it so much,
because I think you know, knowing you,
it's a little bit of a curveball
- [Phil] Yup.
- For me of what you, like,
I'm curious myself, I'm
being serious in a real way,
right, you haven't launched yet,
it's physical locations, which I like
the practicality of that a lot.
I'm a buyer of the payback period.
Curious.
- Belief that they can
pull off experience,
that's next level.
- [Gary] Why?
- Just interacting with them,
spending time with them.
From what I've learned over the years,
and I guess pattern matching.
The fact that there is white space,
they're selling time,
and just the brand resonates with me.
I just like them as people too.
- Yeah.
- I think that's just gonna carry through
the Glowbar brand, their dynamic.
- I think most of our investors right now
are investing in us because of who we are.
Because we have like no revenue to show,
we have a deck, and we have some ideas.
- There's only two things, of course.
The first round of capital
is always people and idea.
Without, there is nothing else.
- Yeah, we think we've
been really thoughtful
about creating something special
and focused on the
consumer and what they need
right now.
I think that's like a winning
strategy, if you ask me.
- Like the forefront of our
minds with every single decision
we ask ourselves, is this
helping her take better
care of her skin than she is today?
And we have heard from almost every female
we've interacted with that
there is something more
she can be doing, but she
just doesn't know what.
And so, knowing that that need is there,
and the fact that we're
building to solve that
is what kind of really motivates us.
- What do you think
happens in a recession?
What's your intuition?
Do you have any data, on what happened
to this space in the 08-09,
I think one of the things
that's running through my mind
is timing, obviously,
this is a luxury-ish,
I mean 70 bucks, it's a luxury.
But I understand the necessity back
to dentist versus dry bar right?
How much or how little,
or what do you think
happens when the bottom falls out?
- So traditional beauty back in like 2008,
when the recession hit,
beauty actually stayed
afloat because it was
a small little luxury
- Look lipstick, lipstick
during the Great Depression,
that I understand.
That's a little bit different than what
you're talking about.
- But I do think that we are,
because the average is
$150 and we're only $70,
I think it will still,
to some, in some markets,
still be considered a more
affordable, accessible
price point that they can
still treat themselves.
- I think that's right, I think,
you could lose a lot of people,
But I wonder,
- I think we'd lose their consistency.
- Yeah, I think the question is,
can you gain enough from the
$150's that need to go to 70?
- Yeah, I think it's a, the
demographic we're going after,
actually helps a little bit, we think that
they are used to seeing 150
and then they'll come to
the 70 and then,
- Are you worried about
people valuing something
based on price, at all,
has that been a discussion?
- Yeah, we've talked
about that, there's like.
- We're having a focus
group for pricing, actually,
just to make sure we're
hitting the nail on
the head with it, and
just like going through
a few scenarios of like
how, psychologically
people are reacting to
the $70 price point,
with the product that we're providing.
Because we're actually
providing the value,
is similar to the 150,
it's just we're able to
cut out all the fluff and make it for $70.
- Have you thought about the basic retail
principle of making it 69 or 79
just because it's, I know, I know, I know.
But like have you thought about that?
Don't be a dirtbag, you know.
- I just don't like the
nine, it drives me nuts.
- Oh the nine bothers you more than like
the silly reference?
- Oh I didn't even.
- I thought that's what
you were laughing at.
- Oh my god, no!
- 69, ha ha ha!
- You're never gonna live that down.
- No,
- You don't like the visual of nine,
let me save you a lot of time
- 69.99 makes me feel like a dollar store.
- Respect.
- We have talked about though.
- We go back and
- I would tell you what I would pay.
I would run google ads and search queries
and run a bunch of
testing and Facebook ads,
like do what Tim Ferris brilliantly did,
Four Hour Workweek was a beta test on
google searches, I would run Facebook,
Instagram, and Google ads, against pricing
of a fake salon landing page,
and see who signs up for what and why.
- That's brilliant.
- I think so, and I think
that we live in 2019,
and you guys can literally, not kidding,
here's what I would do if I were you.
I'd create a fake facial place,
I'm being dead serious, you can call
it Gary's if you'd like.
- You bet, it's called Gary's.
- You should create some
one-off landing pages,
run ads against certain
demos and income levels,
see what people react to,
get their email, right,
and then send a surprise gift to everybody
as like an announcement
for what you're launching.
Seven weeks ago, you filled
out, you know what I mean?
- [Rachel] Yeah
- So, it'll be fun.
You're surprise and delighting them,
you're getting information,
win win win win win.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- And for like $500, of
Instagram and Facebook ads,
you're getting a real meaningful read.
- Yeah.
- That's so smart.
Okay, consider it done.
- It's helpful.
- Let me know how it went.
- We will.
Because you're gonna see it,
Gary's Facial Spa is
launching in New York.
- Anything else I can answer for you?
- So many things.
What do you think?
What do you think of the
rest of this business?
- I'm very obsessed with
the time saving thing.
It's my number one thesis.
I think you're in the branding business.
I think that if you're right,
you're gonna have a lot
of fast followers, and a
lot of people adjusting,
and then that goes away, so I think you're
in the branding business.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- I really do, which is why I'm so
disproportionately excited
about you building up
what are they called again, I apologize.
- Estheticians.
- I think the esthetician
thing is exciting to me
because building a
brand that you pro-that,
is going to be a leverage point over time.
Like tomorrow if I have four facial places
in Long Island, and you're
getting real traction,
I'm like fuck, and like,
and obviously there's things in process,
that allows you to do in 30,
it's something that will
be moved, if you're right,
it gets moved on pretty quickly.
- [Neha] Yeah, that's true.
- And I think like building out brand,
and being loud and proud is important.
- Yeah.
When, so like similar to that,
when you think about our
marketing and kind of what
you've heard a little bit, what's sort of
your reaction to that
of like, really focusing
on like earned media.
And focusing on our product
in the beginning versus
running billboards and Facebook ads for a
brand people don't know yet?
- I would do what you're doing,
I'd probably layer
influencer marketing on top.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- No billboard, no Facebook,
but I would do influencer marketing.
- [Neha] Yup.
- I would also call in favors.
- We count on it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah I mean, I think you like find out
the most fabulous girls
you have in your rolodex
went to school with, friends, homies,
- Just ourselves.
- Respect, but that's only two.
So I really do think, more
friends and family up front,
but friends and family
with a requirement of like,
that's nice, we're giving it to you,
we're not giving it to you
unless you post on Instagram.
- Right.
- Of course.
And that will create organic growth.
- Yeah, I think you
manipulate the organic growth
a little bit upfront, through
influencers that you pay,
and listen, you know
what I don't like about
the startup community yet?
Like not yet, like, in its current form,
it's not desperate enough.
- Yeah.
- I'm completely,
completely out of control
on this direct to consumer
wine brand I launched.
I'm hustling and grinding
and being so ghetto,
and I have all the leverage and money.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- And I'm still doing it
because it's my natural state.
It's a new baby.
This is where you like swallow pride
and e-mail some girl that
didn't say something nice
about you but doesn't know that you know,
and still ask her to do
it because it's good for
your fucking business.
- Yeah, we definitely
are gonna get scrappy.
- Do you understand that?
- I know that they're gonna do that,
and that's another reason they're here.
I felt that.
- I actually wanna show you.
- Your heartless is done with.
- I wanna show you, I
don't know if I'm gonna
be able to find it.
- I highly recommend,
you were asked a question,
you're not going to provide
(laughter)
- I don't know if I'm going
to be able to find this
fast enough, be we have a great campaign,
it's super scrappy for
like telephone poles, like,
- Scratching your guerrilla
marketing campaign itch
that you've had your whole life,
versus, yes, Tyler?
I gotta go?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
Versus, influencer fucking marketing, and
most fab girls you know calling favors,
being annoying,
- Okay, be annoying.
- Be annoying, listen, the cool thing is
it's like me when I'm going to be annoying
when the actual rose comes out,
I'm going to be annoying to tell people
I wanna send them a bottle of rose,
to take a picture and put on Instagram,
but they can drink it,
like being annoying again,
like you need a mix, right?
You need Instagram gal
that's got a big following,
that's width, but like, you know like,
somebody you were friends with that like
fancy, consulting firm who's got 1700, but
she's alpha scarsdale matters too.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- [Neha] Yeah.
- High - low.
- Yeah, sure.
- High, low.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Thanks, guys.
- Really appreciate it.
- Real pleasure.
- So great meeting you.
- Can we get one pic with you?
- You sure can.
- Just so like,
- Just one.
- We have proof, because I feel like our
family thinks we're lying.
- Hey, I'm Phil Toronto, I'm SVP of
Special Projects with Gary.
We just wrapped our meeting
with Rachel and Neha
of Glowbar.
If you want to follow
along in their opening
journey, you can follow them on Instagram
@Glowbar, or sign up for their newsletter
at getglowbar.com
(slow electronic music)